Estas son las fuertes medidas y no las
sanciones económicas a varios cargos e
instituciones aprobadas ayer que china
había prometido la semana pasada chichá
ingüen la presidenta taiwanesa y Kevin
mccarthy presidente de la cámara de
representantes se reunían en Estados
Unidos no son originales porque ya envió
china sus barcos y aviones de guerra al
estrecho de formosa después de que Nancy
pelosi predecesora de macarthy se viera
con SAE en verano pasado la presidenta
había intentado rebajar el enfado de
Pekín con un perfil bajo en su visita a
Estados Unidos canceló los actos de
mayor enjundia política minimizó la
cobertura mediática y se reunió con
mccarthy en una biblioteca y no en una
sede oficial china ha criticado durante
toda la semana lo que define como la
cínica política del tránsito es decir
que la presidenta taiwanesa en su
periplo por Centroamérica para reunirse
con los pocos aliados diplomáticos que
le quedan haga pasar por simples escalas
técnicas sus paradas en Estados Unidos
para citarse con representantes
políticos
Washington también había pedido a Pekín
que no sobreactuara por unas prácticas
que forman parte de la casuística las
maniobras anunciadas por Pekín serán más
cortas que aquellas ordenadas tras la
visita de pelosi Y al menos en su primer
día han contado con menos barcos y
aviones de guerra parece una solución a
medio camino que intenta compatibilizar
la necesidad de exteriorizar su ira ante
cualquier interacción de un cargo
político taiwanés con otro
estadounidense con el tono menos
beligerante que ha adoptado
recientemente con taipei para no
arruinar las expectativas del partido
más cercano a Pekín en las próximas
elecciones presidenciales de